what do you think JLo does to get these
up I don't know but I want to know and I
but even if I knew I probably would do
it
Jayla was supposed to be here later
today so we're gonna see if she's into
her own it is JLo no her abs I would
here's the thing we saw JLo for a second
she looks like a goddess she's glowing
for a mile away she's in her birthday
suit and buy her birthday suit I mean
Versace yeah Jayla was born in Versace
oh she loves so she has great AB she is
great at JLo is getting closer and we
can we can feel it I can really feel the
heat the temperature just went up five
degrees Jenny from the block god he's
amazing I'm not gonna lie to you guys
underneath this is that exact body very
much
they bought same bad I can see JLo she's
up on the platform right now with any
luck we'll be splashed by her swag I got
five minutes
JLo watch 2k15 how do you think she gets
that money I don't know but I want to
ask her I only see her nose and she
looks incredible just her nose looks
better than the rest of my body JLo is
at least 20 years older than the average
person here and looks 37 years better
that didn't that wasn't even a real
thing yes it is it totally is JLo how
cute is she oh my god is it weird that
I'm attracted to my mom I mean if your
mom Stella she is beautiful
he didn't know his mom's ABS his own
mom's he was into them which was weird
it's all right it was JLo so if Jayla
was my mom I'd be under her ABS TBH oh
my god she looked at me I'm pregnant
right now
halo [ __ ] JLo walking she J goes she
Jesus JLo she like Benjamin Button 'td
as she walked down the carpet I think
she just got younger oh there she goes
goodbye JLo JLo watches over and it's
been a minute now
we're still thinking about jello recipes
J Lo's presents I'm gonna I'm gonna take
this thank you very much you're welcome
there he goes with his mom's back ladies
gentlemen another Tyler Posey